in mali's capital bamako celebrations of
a military Victory the northern town of
kidal is no longer in the hands of taric
rebels but the country's Army the fact
that the Army has been able to recapture
kadal is an immense Joy this is just the
beginning we're going to flush them out
and take back the whole of Mali in 2014
mali's prime minister was forced to
resigned by taric rebels now they're the
ones fleeing the town they say they have
retreated for strategic
reasons all the armed AAW forces have
decided to ret treat just to save lives
also to reather their uh forces again
but this is not the end of the war but
it's the the beginning of new one since
October mali's military have been
pounding kidal with drone strikes and
Russian mercenaries have fought
alongside mali's Special Forces to
defeat the
tuaregs these are are the Vagner group
Fighters walking into the
town today the impossible has become
possible because a lot of people thought
we couldn't reconquer kidel at all but
it's done so I'm filled with joy filled
with pride despite the celebrations in
bamako thousands of Arab and trar
residents are fleeing kidal they fear
this may not be the end of a battle but
the beginning of a bigger conflict
engulfing Northern Molly Nicholas Hawk
Al jazer darar